bienvenue vous êtes sur envergure
podcast et site internet spécialiste du
scouting basketball avant la draft NBA
2023 on prend les candidats les jeunes
un par un on vous donne l'essentiel sur
chacun voici notre épisode compte
consacré à Julian stravers
[Musique]
née le 18 avril 2002 on dit bien
strodeur si vous voulez prononcer
correctement ça veut dire que il aura
déjà eu ces 21 ans il les a déjà à
l'heure on enregistre mais il aura ses
21 ans le soir de la draft de mettre de
haut 94 kg de mètres 0,7 d'envergure
voilà ce qu'on trouve sur sa fiche sur
envergure.co plutôt un ailier il était
48e dans la dernière actualisation du
Big board ispn 27ème chez CBS et chez
nous 38e donc on est dans on est dans la
moyenne fin de premier début de second
tour pour en parler aujourd'hui nous
sommes avec Julien et Hugues salut les
gars
présent
très bien il est il ne manque pas à
l'appel et pour ces portraits et bien on
commence toujours par la biographie qui
qui sait qui qui sait Julian stroder
vas-y Julien c'est à toi
alors strowser originaire de Las Vegas
dans le Nevada et d'origine de Puerto
Rico alors pourquoi je commence comme ça
parce que c'est un garçon qui est très
attaché à sa communauté que ce soit
celle de Puerto Rico ou que ce soit
c'est du Nevada ou jeune lycéen il a
laissé une forte marque
un joueur qui faisait du chiffre là-bas
mais il a aussi par sa personnalité
marquée
sa communauté
pareil du côté de ses origines il a il a
participé au Shiba U19 en Grèce en
devine neuf en 2019 pardon et il est
toujours très motivé pour poursuivre sa
carrière avec son équipe nationale donc
voilà c'est un donc jeune de Las Vegas
il est donc à Gonzaga depuis maintenant
trois ans il a commencé comme beaucoup
de jeunes à Gonzaga avec un très petit
enjeu sa première année puis maintenant
il est il est titulaire installé
et avec un temps de jeu qui était en
hausse depuis il y a deux ans voilà
voilà pour la personnalité ce que on a
des fun facts sur Julien strozer ce
qu'il a une nourriture préférée
tout le monde a Hugues pour les fun
facts
ouais il est en tout cas effectivement
très très attaché à
sa communauté et on note sur sa fiche
Wikipédia je ne savais pas que qu'il a
perdu sa mère très jeune peut-être que
ça forge aussi un petit peu le caractère
Hugues on parle désormais du contexte de
Julien strother Julien l'a dit ça jouait
à Gonzaga
quel rôle il avait dans cette équipe
quelle année il a fait
ouais c'est un rôle qui a pas mal évolué
sur ces trois ans
l'an dernier année de chat engren entre
autres et de Andrew Neymar maintenant
NBA il était vraiment sur un rôle en
offball un rôle de Catane shooter pour
nous un rôle de mec qui cute partout qui
court tout le temps et qui fait beaucoup
beaucoup de tirs cette année du coup on
perd quand même de gros de gros joueurs
du côté des Bulldogs et il a été un peu
plus responsable du scoring un peu plus
compter sur lui alors toujours beaucoup
de tirs extérieurs c'est ça marque de
fabrique avec un tire donc voilà un
petit peu plus tard plus de missions
défensive aussi un peu plus
de responsabilité ballonnement dans
l'attaque du panier donc voilà un rôle
qui a évolué mais on devrait quand même
je pense
s'intéresser à son
moitié à son contexte année
2021-2022 pour une projection NBA c'est
ce qui sera le plus probable sur la
suite de sa carrière comme comme rôle
d'accord et alors dans ce dans ce rôle
là qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on avait
en terme de je suis en train de regarder
en même temps qu'on parle le taux de
d'usage par exemple de Julian strausser
je peux te dire que c'est le deuxième
volume de terre de l'équipe donc
derrière optimi à l'ordre timide prenez
sentir de plus donc c'est quand même
quelque chose de très l'année dernière
non cette année pour moi c'est l'année
révolue donc cette année ouais il prend
son tir de moins par contre un peu plus
d'évolution dans le dans le pas 3 points
alors c'est léger mais l'an dernier on
est sur 99% de catchange à 3 points
cette année on est sur du
82%. donc ça reste toujours une grosse
dominante mais on voit qu'il a un peu
plus posé le ballon moins de bonne
efficacité vers le cercle
près du panier ça montre aussi comme il
a eu plus de ballons en main que lorsque
les défenses étaient focaliser sur lui
moins de moins de réussite et des
progrès par contre dans le dans le
lancer franc donc un joueur qui a pu
évoluer avec une mécanique de tir un
petit peu à la plus académique et on
détaille un peu par la suite alors on a
le contexte donc Gonzaga qui est une
équipe qui a fait qui a fait une bonne
saison pour pour rentrer dans les
chiffres et pour montrer l'évolution que
tu décrivais Hugues il est passé de
2021-2022 taux d'usage donc taux de
possession qui qui passe par lui enfin
dans le le nombre de temps où il a le
ballon quand le quand il est sur le
terrain se dit il est à moins de 19%
l'année dernière il y a plus de 22%
cette année
et avec du coup un taux de balle perdu
qui a augmenté aussi donc la lourde
enfin la charge plus lourde il l'a ça
s'est ressenti dans son efficacité comme
tu le disais que ce soit affiché and
feel goal pour syntage ou que ce soit
pourcentage de bal perdu en ce qui
concerne ce que tu disais sur les les
tirs de près il est à 62% en clause tout
donc ce sont les paniers à moins de
tenter à moins de 10 pieds si je dis pas
de bêtises ou de 5 pieds à moins d'un
mètre 50 je crois du cercle
on passe à son point fort
puisque dans ces dans ces formats
portraits dans ces formats l'essentiel
sur Julian strowser l'essentiel à savoir
pour le soir de la draft c'est pourquoi
il va être drafté Julien pourquoi est-ce
qu'on draft je viens de strowser
c'est un ailier de 2 mètres qui shootent
et qui a un corps déjà
affirmer
je pense que c'est ça qui
c'est sa porte d'entrée
gros shooter comme a dit Hugues en
calcium shoot assez rapide quand même
assez rapide même si comme tu l'as dit
c'est un geste qui est non académique
mais je crois que à partir de des
pourcentages qui développent
à deux à trois et au lancer franc il y a
pas trop de souci à te faire par rapport
à la mécanique on est plus là en
carrière
38% à 3 points en carrière et cette
année même
41% quasiment sur quasiment
10-3 points sur 100 possession donc ce
sont des chiffres assez impressionnant
et il a progressé au lancer France qui
un peu bon il est toujours à moins de
80% mais il a quand même corrigé le tir
par rapport à
ce qu'on pouvait voir dans les premières
années ce qui était pas vraiment en
corrélation avec un shooter d'élite
quand on dit geste peu académique Hugues
de quoi on parle et en quoi ça peut le
gêner on a un cœur qui parle assez bas
on a vraiment un fouetté de poignet avec
un tiers qui part qui part très bas donc
ça permet de déclencher rapidement mais
ça permet aussi forcément de se faire
contester par des joueurs plus petits et
par des joueurs qui ne qui m'ont pas
avoir besoin de faire d'énormes efforts
dans le dans l'envergure pour pouvoir le
le contester mais ce sera pas je pense
très problématique ça surtout que le
joueur met très efficace dans tous les
compartiments du 3 points je veux dire
qu'il a pas une une main dominante c'est
pas parce qu'il reçoit le ballon sur sa
main forte qui va être plus efficace il
est dans tous les côtés côté gauche côté
droit à 45 degrés même dans les CORN il
a plus de 40% donc vraiment dans la
projection catchan shoot pure il le fera
très très bien et pour développer un peu
sur le tir comme skill c'est un joueur
qui se réacte assez rapidement vers le
panier c'est pas un énorme matelet on a
un peu parlé c'est pas c'est pas un
golgot c'est pas un mec hyper puissant
mais il se réaix très rapidement il se
rééquilibré rapidement donc on peut être
de la sortie d'écran aussi et déclencher
au niveau supérieur effectivement ça
c'est très important et et on le voit
d'avoir plusieurs cordes à son arc si on
est juste un shooter pied dans le béton
entre guillemets dans le corner il faut
être un énorme défenseur pour pouvoir
jouer quoi en tout cas en playoff NBA
juste tu parlais de son corps déjà bien
bien formé est-ce que ça veut dire que
défensivement on peut l'imaginer sur
plusieurs positions des fentes sur
plusieurs positions comment ça se
traduit dans dans son impact physique
sur le terrain et comment ça peut se
traduire au niveau supérieur
non c'est pas forcément facile à juger
parce que il a défendu surtout sur des
extérieurs en fait ils défend surtout
sur les sur des deux ou des trois moi
j'ai l'impression que ça soit alors plus
tard mais voir que il se coltine des
gens des quatre quoi voilà
c'est un gars qui a des épaules assez
larges qui est qui est qui peut jouer un
peu sur sur sa lourdeur
qui est
assez rapide sur sur des petits espaces
qui mais par contre il y a pas une
grosse rapidité nord-sud
[Musique]
défensivement il est il a changé quoi je
trouve il a évolué et je pense que ça
c'est un aspect important de son jeu
c'est qu'il continue à évoluer même à
l'âge que tu as donné et au niveau
défensif il s'implique beaucoup
il a il a une je trouve une bonne
compréhension de la circulation il
arrive bien à passer les écrans à
comprendre les les déplacements des
joueurs qui suit ça c'est intéressant
mais est-ce qu'il va défendre sur des
sur ce type de joueurs NBA je sais pas
tu voulais rajouter quelque chose
la finalité quand même défensive le
rebond
c'est un joueur qui est très présent à
ce niveau là pas un énorme athlète
verticale mais toujours très bien placé
qui
a un vrai travail collectif
effectivement il a eu une année
donc 2021 2022 on lui demande en gros de
rabattre sur chaton graine pour que je
tombe graine contre ce que tu es en
train de très très bien et cette année
c'est une routes semi sous le panier
donc c'est pas exactement le même rôle
et on lui a on lui a demandé de venir un
peu plus stopper en premier rideau il a
réussi à le faire aussi
j'ai fait souvent l'erreur de
sous-estimer les comment dire les
athlètes moyens pour les élus en me
disant bah ils se feront passer sur tous
les switchs la réalité pour l'instant
NBA c'est que ces mecs arrivent à être
positif quand vraiment donnant une
direction et en utilisant leur longueur
ils sont beaucoup plus utilisés qu'avant
je trouve sur les petits on voit encore
dans les play-offs donc j'ai pas trop
trop d'inquiétude là-dessus et comme
c'est un bourreau bondeur en plus je
vois bien un impact au moins neutre
voire positif sur le peu de temps de jeu
qui devrait avoir quand même dans les
dans les premières années alors
justement on parle juste tu disais
qu'elle va être son rôle dès l'année
prochaine quelle peut être son rôle dès
l'année prochaine dans la franchise qui
le draft en partant du principe
évidemment on fait toujours ça on part
du principe qu'il aura quand même un peu
de temps de jeu
même s'il est draftés 35e
moi je le vois bien comment
jouer ou défendre en tout cas sur des
postes 3-4 parce qu'il a pas des trois
un peu lent quoi il a pas la vitesse
suffisante pour pour défendre sur des
ailiers au niveau supérieur je pense et
puis
[Musique]
je pense que dans un bon collectif
inséré dans un bon collectif dans un il
pourrait apporter son écho en attaque en
4ème shoot quoi ce sera faux une fois
qu'il pose le ballon par terre qu'est-ce
qui se passe est-ce que c'est une
catastrophe est-ce que c'est un peu non
l'évolution il a un très très beau
toucher moi je trouve moi j'aime bien
quand il est il lance son mineur là
c'est vraiment chouette quoi il a une
belle petite main droite pour pour finir
alors il est pas puissant au contact ça
c'est sûr il est pas très
aérien et très puissant au contact mais
il a cette capacité à
à faire du leanner et puis à se battre
aussi au niveau du démarrage aussi c'est
quelqu'un qui ont qui sait se démarquer
qui aiment ça j'ai l'impression on se
déplacer à travers la défense et jouer
avec les écrans ok
Hugues est-ce que tu vois des choses à
travailler en priorité justement dans le
but d'avoir du temps de jeu rapidement
je pense pas qu'il va y avoir une énorme
évolution de du joueur juste
s'accommoder à cette ligue et puis si il
fait partie de la catégorie des des bons
jours de basket il y en a qui jouent à
qui jouent pas il y a des One d'elmour
qui jouent pas dans les une par exemple
qui sont des bons joueurs de basket tu
as des Jordan networa qui ne qui étaient
des bons joueurs de basket un peu
similaires et qui jouent pas et puis tu
as des mecs comme Christian Brown qui
ont du temps de jeu un jour et qui qui
montrent qu'ils sont qui sont talentueux
et repérageon aussi donc je pense que ça
remonte une question d'opportunité en
tout cas je tu sais ce que tu as tu sais
ce que tu achètes et ça coûte pas cher
c'est forcément utile donc le il y a
quand même des voyants positifs pour une
carrière professionnelle faudra juste
que et sa chance et tu vois tu vois une
évolution quand même est-ce que on peut
imaginer une évolution à son jeu au
joueur qu'on voit aujourd'hui ou qu'on a
vu l'année dernière la semaine dernière
à Gonzaga pour se projeter un peu sur la
fin de son son premier contrat justement
c'est ce qui est dans la tête des
équipes parce que le draft ce sera
peut-être du développement physique de
venir plus puissant mieux encaisser le
contact moins se désaxer moi je dirais
là dessus surtout si on embauche des
missions défensives vraiment ne pas
exploser et offensivement être capable
parce que les joueurs vont commencer à
claraître quand il aura mis trois fils
dans le corner et qui vont comprendre
qu'il faut pas le laisser être capable
du coup d'aller vers le panier et
d'utiliser ce flotteur leader main
droite qui fait très très bien donc
voilà pour moi ça va vraiment être une
une prise physique qui va falloir qu'il
va falloir passer il a il a Jul il a
cette carrure quand même pour ajouter
encore de la masse on a l'impression
quand on le regarde
il a des épaules assez larges et
on sent que ça peut ça peut se
développer après c'est un joueur malin
moi je trouve que c'est un joueur malin
il faut il est dans alors parfois c'est
un peu c'est un peu drôle parce que
il part par exemple au contre
il sait très bien qu'il va pas qui va
pas y aller vraiment
il fait des petites choses comme ça ou
il montre qu'il est présent sans trop
faire quoi et mais bon là c'est le côté
un peu négatif quoi il est c'est un gars
qui est un peu t-il quoi il a un petit
peu décontracté tout le temps mais je
pense qu'il a un côté très malin il a un
côté très collectif qui peut l'aider à
s'insérer au NBA je pense et il a du
caractère quand même
qui se cache pas il se cache pas ils
sont
il faudrait voir le match contre Yukon
sa première mi-temps moi je pensais que
je m'étais trompé de
porte que j'avais fait c'est il peut
quand il a quand il a quand il a faim il
est il est très actif il est très
dynamique
ça peut ça peut révéler aussi des
joueurs Julian strover donc de gonzagas
si vous allez voir des images ou des
matchs les uns les autres qui nous
écoutent
profitez-en pour observer de routimi
qu'on a mentionné si vous ne si vous ne
savez pas qui c'est cette un beau
bandeau une belle moustache et selon
Alan Guillou des marchés à chaque action
alors on vous laissera juger
on finit comme d'habitude
est-ce qu'on y croit ou pas as-tu
l'instruer et ce qu'on y croit ou pas
alors évidemment c'est toujours une
question de contexte etc mais voilà je
vous demande de vous mouiller messieurs
lors de cette de ces dernières minutes
oui non et argumentation une trentaine
de secondes qui commence
moi j'y crois parce qu'en fait ça fait
ouais ça fait presque deux ans qu'il
joue dans un rôle très proche de ce qui
pourrait faire en NBA au niveau de
l'attaque
et puis il y a ce
physique qui va suivre je pense
et puis comme voilà il est malin ok
donc je y crois et Hugues
pas cher ça met des ça met des trois
points c'est un profil didoine vraiment
pour pour avoir une chance et
normalement il devrait pas se rater vu
que il fait ce qu'il fait il le fait
très bien
très bien et bien Julian stroder est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à ajouter
sur sur le profil du joueur que vous
aviez noté dans vos dans vos petits
scouting report pour le complet à
l'écrit je précise que il est disponible
sur le site envergure.co écrit par par
toi Julien
donc effectivement assez
complet aussi pour pour pouvoir se faire
une idée du joueur si on ne si vous avez
si vous avez manqué des parties de ce
podcast messieurs quelque chose à
ajouter
nous allons clore donc l'essentiel sur
Julian strowser c'était notre portrait à
voir chez qui il se s'il sera drafté
d'abord et puis si oui chez qui le
joueur originaire de Porto et du Nevada
à bientôt tout le monde